[Music]
kobe bryant right cody brown my boy
mamba all right the mamba it was 8 24 i
don't know when this video was coming
out but it was 8 24 recently it was kobe
day and one big big piece of news
dropped on kobe day where
a
jury awarded
vanessa bryant
16 million dollars
over the crash photos that were taken of
kobe and daughter gianna that were like
leaked out by like you know police and
firefighters and stuff like that all
these grizzly photos that caused
emotional trauma distress and damage to
her whole family because people just
wanted to go viral well i mean
i mean it didn't not even like that just
like the kind of way that like a normal
dude would just go hey check this out i
got the kobe photos yeah you should well
you shouldn't release those photos yeah
you should that's [ __ ] up they weren't
even supposed to
like acknowledge that they existed it
wasn't supposed to leave the department
so it was cops doing it who who paid who
who paid the 16 million the city of l.a
city of la yup kobe bryant's widow
vanessa was awarded 16 million as part
of a 31 million jury verdict wednesday
against elliott county for deputies and
firefighters sharing grisly photos of
the nba star the 13 year old daughter
gianna and other victims killed in a
2020 helicopter crash
the nine jurors unanimously agreed with
vanessa bryant and her attorneys that
the photos invaded her privacy and
caused emotional distress
she cried quietly as the verdict was
read but are they really getting
punished though because that's just
taxpayer money like it should come out
of everyone involved because they have
to be penalized
like
the people that
shared it did the did the actions like
are there consequences for them like if
they got fired or something yeah yeah or
like or or did they get personally fined
prob maybe they probably do get fired
right because
probably what they did is a breach
someone got fired right now almost
someone got fired everyone gets on paid
leave because it was high ranking people
wasn't it was like a sheriff's deputy
and then the other person's like a fire
chief or some [ __ ] [ __ ] are they doing
like a fire captain can you imagine
someone's like did you see those
pictures like i don't know man john was
trying to show me some [ __ ] but i was
definitely like i did not want to see it
so i don't know what we were talking
about
that's the part that's scary right it's
like she was saying that she will never
know if it's out there or not
oh that sucks yeah she says uh i haven't
seen no pictures of it it says the
pictures were shared mostly among
employees of the los angeles county
sheriffs and fire departments including
uh by some who were playing video games
and attending an awards banquet they
also were seen by some of their spouses
and in one case by a bartender at a bar
where a deputy was drinking how did they
now
how did their family know they were
doing this
did it start leaking online it says
vanessa bryant tearfully testified
during the 11 day trial that news of the
photos compounded her still raw grief a
month after the deaths of her husband
and daughter and that she has
has panic attacks at the thought that
the photos might still be out there
she said quote i live in fear every day
of being on social media and these
popping up she testified i live in fear
of my daughters being on social media
and these popping up her co-plaintiff
chris chester whose wife and daughter
were among the nine people killed in the
crash was awarded 15 million dollars
we're grateful for a jury and a judge
who gave us a fair trial he says
vanessa's bryant's uh vanessa bryant's
attorneys did not give jurors a dollar
amount they thought their client
deserved but chester's attorney gave
them suggested guidelines that would
that would have meant tens of millions
for each plaintiff
vanessa bryant and her attorney declined
comment outside court wednesday her face
was still shrieked with tears as she
walked past tv cameras and dozens of
reporters
um her lawyer told jurors that the
close-up photos had no official or
investigative purpose
and were mere quote visual gossip shared
out of a gruesome curiosity that sucks
man someone with an iphone on the scene
yeah just
snapping away because it wasn't like it
was taken with the official
city camera that you can't like take the
[ __ ] that's a 30 million it's not 16
that's a 30 million dollar [ __ ] up by
some people on the damn but you are
the police department it doesn't say
anything about like you know the
deputies the sheriffs because it look if
anything based on off that information
like now you've got
possibly many people
involved you know what i mean sheriff's
deputies firefighters blah blah blah
like a lot of random people that are in
the system so it's like how do you
how do you exact justice on them so the
state the city governments everything
right
they have a slush fund with our tax
money so like let's say you're paying
they the way they collect taxes is if
they have state income tax like from
your income right they'll take like
whatever percentage the state's gonna
take and then the city takes [ __ ] um or
like through commerce like
depending on
what that state's rule is it could be
from sales tax so like let's say you buy
food and then they stack on like eight
percent so all this money goes to the
city and it goes to the state right and
then they pick and choose what they want
to do with it a lot of them have a fund
just for these issues like that like for
lawsuits for whatever for scandal for
hush money like they don't call it hush
money but they call it like settling out
of court because whenever there's sexual
harassment rape some kind of [ __ ] up
[ __ ] that politicians do
um high level like people in office or
in like fire department police
department
this is where the money comes from
it's like the city had to pay this much
money the it doesn't come out of
anybody's pocket but the citizens who
helped them save up for these [ __ ] up
things so that's that's just like shitty
to me because it's like no one there's
no consequences for them but i think
it's supposed to impact how
they move forward right like supposed to
yeah i'm sure there's a whole time you
know what boys clubs of things and how
it's been treated forever i'm sure
there's like polaroids or pictures of
all kinds of crazy [ __ ] from the history
of time of [ __ ] they did and they did
this kind of [ __ ] that's a culture of i
mean i'm just making them in my head
right culture of how things go but now
when these things hit it's like the
culture has to change we cannot
yeah but
if there's no clear like uh consequence
yeah like burning these fools at the
stake and and doing a public hanging
yeah where it's clear that that society
gets this consequential lesson for doing
some sort of wrong or immoral practicing
we don't know if they still working we
don't know if they got moved to another
department we don't know anything all
the time i'm sure somebody knows i hope
they do i [ __ ] hope they do the only
thing this endorses to me is that if
somebody kind of [ __ ] up there's some
sort of slush fund that i might be able
to sue the city for yeah yeah and with
other crazy like you know obviously i
don't think vanessa bryant needs 16 more
million or i don't know who the other
guy was but i'm they probably all roll
deep in a private helicopter i mean i
don't know if that dude needs another 15
million either or not the fire chief who
leaked it is already retired oh he was
forced into retirement dude this shit's
gonna keep happening it's not gonna stop
it's not i think honestly it's human
nature like i got friends that are like
police officers and stuff and when they
see crazy [ __ ]
they just take pictures that's just like
human nature yeah like when we see like
two people going like yelling at a
[ __ ] football game you know we're
just nosy but when you see the chat at
least it's in their mind oh you don't
share it like this is crazy like you
might still have the human nature
jumping i mean you should already know
better than not to do that but now you
know for sure
not to do that [ __ ] but at the same time
if you're a quote unquote like um a
civilian a normal person right
and then that's that's like a celebrity
that did some [ __ ] yeah but that's
different because like let's say you saw
the crash and you're some like farmer
and you're like god dang it what the
hell was that and then you run over
there you're like oh my god
still california oh calabasas
like men and black in the beginning like
a lot of people would probably do it
when you think about but yeah if you're
someone that's on the job yeah a cop or
a farmer he's like you're supposed to be
a better you're supposed to be perfect
from a higher standard yeah yeah that's
what it said that like they said that
they ordered seven
officers to take photos
and that they have to do it in a certain
specific manner that's consistent with
the values of you know the job and
the guys that leaked it didn't do that
so that's it that's kind of like if a
surgeon
was working on [ __ ] a celebrity and
he's like oh i can't believe i got the
[ __ ] titties of mariah carey and then
they're taking photos and then they're
like hey check it out you want to see
some carry titties but he was really
supposed to x-ray her molar yeah right
right right it's not like you're some
paparazzi you're a you're a doctor yeah
so exactly uh
county attorney jay mira hashmall argued
during the trial that the photos were a
necessary tool for assessing the
situation and that's why the bartender
had to see it too
[Laughter]
yeah she acknowledged that they should
not have been shared with everyone who
saw them but she emphasized that the
photos had never appeared publicly and
had never been seen by the plaintiffs
she said that uh that meant that sheriff
alex villanueva and other officials had
taken decisive and effective action when
they ordered those who had the photos to
delete them so yeah that's like yeah i
might get that too like is it really 31
million dollars mistake or is it like a
number let's fire your food people that
are never gonna make 31 million dollars
in their lifetime anyway yeah i'm just
i'm just gonna fire six guys [ __ ] it
yeah i'm saying so it never it was never
released the public that's i don't know
but i'm curious how they even knew that
these photos were circulating
because someone had a whistle blow that
yeah somebody probably did and then they
launched an investigation and they found
it i remember it being a big issue like
the day that it happened yeah when it
happened that was like as big as that
was as big as holy [ __ ] these photos
were getting leaked everywhere and like
it was even messing with the
investigation because now there's
evidence something got leaked out or
they could even make a conclusion on
anything dude i remember when that day
dude it was like that [ __ ] [ __ ] me up
i was at the it's one of those days when
you remember where you were yeah that's
like 9 11 and michael jackson was the
only other two times i've ever felt the
pantry i was a little at the pantry
downtown like the restaurant the
restaurant the restaurant we were
kicking and eating and then
also i just saw everybody looking at
their phone you know it's one of those
moments we're like what the [ __ ] we were
at a business shop on their phone i was
like let me just phone and it was like
kobe i was like i'm so sad and you're
like that's not real no let me see i was
right i could see the staple center from
where i was at and i was like i'm so sad
that [ __ ] your whole thing up yeah i
was in a [ __ ] meeting with the vp of
one of the vps of nike wow and i was the
[ __ ] person who revealed the news to
their team no because i got a text from
my girl and then in the middle of this
[ __ ] exec meeting at an old complex i
just go
[Music]
and then i cut the [ __ ] meeting off
everybody and mike's like okay well you
have to tell everybody now
and it was just a capstocks and i was
and i [ __ ] struggled to find my
breath because i didn't know what to say
and i'm like looking at them all i'm
like kobe bryant just died and the whole
[ __ ] meeting ended like they
immediately started whispering amongst
themselves they're like you guys
understand like we have to and it just
[ __ ] shut the whole meeting down
that's [ __ ] crazy you ruined the
meeting anthony lee
he did you ruined your own opportunity
yeah let's need his fault are we gonna
reschedule this or no no
last meeting we're out here
you